congresswoman rashida talib calling for
the diminishing role of our nation's top
immigration
agencies including ice and customs and
border control even really the
department of homeland security writ
large
this comes from her in response to the
biden administration requesting 665
million dollars to modernize land ports
of entry and an additional
47 million for border surveillance
technology
a lot of republicans say the
congresswoman here is way off base
they want to turn america into a
sanctuary country
for all illegal aliens from around the
world uh
and now that logic is being extended to
our border patrol
and immigrations and custom enforcement
even all of dhs
i think order open border chaos is
exactly what she wants you can't be that
dumb
to think that if you take away funding
from those agencies to protect our
border
that somehow you're not going to have
chaos at the border
house minority whip steve scalise joins
me now congressman thanks so much for
taking time for us today
um with this current iteration of calls
for defunding and diminishing the role
of department of homeland security and i
say this current iteration because it's
certainly not the first time we've
we've heard calls for this from
progressives
do you get the sense from where you sit
that this push is coming from the
president
or is it likelier that it's coming from
the progressive wing of his party maybe
even including
vice president kamala harris it seems to
me from where i sit there's a little bit
of a divide
yeah jillian it's good to be with you
and frankly it's very disturbing when
you hear
a sitting member of congress referring
to people who are keeping our nation
secure as
terrorists i've been down with the
border patrol agents i went down there
a few months ago and we actually went
and saw just how out of control the
border is
because of president biden's policies
where he's literally opened the border
the real big concern is that right now
it's the drug cartels from mexico who
are
who have operational control over
america's southern border
and the democrat party has become more
and more in washington the party of
defunding police
defunding border patrol defunding ice
who's
standing up for americans who are hard
working who want
to have a functioning legal system of
immigration including by the way the
millions of people who
come here legally who wait in line who
follow the process
and so i think they're they're first of
all they're way out of step with the
american people
but the left the far left radical base
of the democrat party is controlling
the agenda and president biden is
letting them write these policies
he has yet to stand up to any of them
i'm curious to see
jillian is president biden going to
speak out against
a sitting member of congress referring
to our border patrol agents
as terrorists people who work for his
department of homeland security
he's yet to show he's willing to stand
up to them interesting so it seems like
you're saying
it's one thing to not for the president
to not be on the same side and not
overtly support these policies
it's another thing if he's actually
going to take a stand and condemn the
people in his party that are calling for
these moves
i want to make sure sir that we get your
take on big tech today it's very hot
story for us
on the same day that former president
trump announced his lawsuit yesterday
against facebook and google and twitter
we did have a house caucus
republicans unveiled this legislative
agenda to break up big tech
and crack down on censorship the house
judiciary committee ranking member jim
jordan said he's spearheading
spearheading the effort and he wants uh
big tech has targeted conservatives for
far too long house judiciary republicans
have had enough so my question for you
sir is you know we've been hearing for
months
years really threats from lawmakers both
sides of the aisle
to rein in and really legislate uh
big tech the social media companies
you guys excel at these like marathon
hearings where you drag the ceos up
to the hill you demand answers from them
but we've seen really very little by way
of legislation is this like the big
kahuna push now that we've all been
waiting for do you think
yeah this has been growing for a long
time and frankly republicans and
democrats both have concerns with big
tech
for different reasons on our side we're
very concerned about the censorship that
you're seeing
of conservative voices way way more than
you see
other voices being censored by big tech
i think that's
what president trump was getting at but
what leader mccarthy did is rolled out a
bunch of task forces
one of them dealing specifically with
big tech jim jordan's going to be
involved kathryn mcmorris rogers is
going to be involved
all of our leading republicans in those
subject areas are going to be focused on
how to hold big tech more accountable
and also by the way standing up for
transparency and for the privacy rights
of everyday americans who right now no
matter what app you're using they're
tracking
things that you may not even realize and
there's very a little way for a consumer
to find out exactly what is being
tracked on their device
if you're just having a conversation
with a friend about
going hiking next thing you know you're
getting things fed to you advertisements
about hiking
uh you never even typed anything into a
google search so
those are the kind of things that people
are very concerned about we're looking
into all of that
and putting a task force together so
that we can come up with true
legislative proposals
so there is this perception sir
here in washington at least that
congress writ large is busy sort of
fixing the problems of two to ten years
ago when it comes to
holding big tech accountable i hear a
lot of critics saying
you guys lawmakers are about two to ten
years behind the problem you're kind of
building the maginot line and solving
the
problems of decades ago when these big
tech companies are moving in leaps and
bounds
and coming up with new innovative ways
to try and gather
data from americans so that they can
keep it
they can essentially resell that
repackage and then resell that data
to companies some of them foreign what
are you doing on that end of the
spectrum
yeah you know like i used to write
software for a living i have a computer
science degree and one of the things
i've always said is
the technology community can innovate
faster than congress can legislate
and you know one of the things you've
got to look at now is privacy
is the next realm and it's it's not you
don't pay for apps anymore it's because
they're aggregating
data from people who use these apps and
people have very little information
about just what is being tracked just
what
data is being collected and then sold uh
unbeknownst mostly to the consumer
it's very hard to even find out what
that information is that they're
tracking
and selling in aggregate form and so
trying to get a better
better handle getting more transparency
is going to be something real important
that we're going to try to do
well congressman thanks for taking time
to break it down for us today we wish
you the best with the task force
going forward please come back to check
in with us sometime soon
we'll do thanks jillian you're back hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now